مشهد لا يبدو غريبا على تنظيم داعش لكن
القصه تهم مختلفه
الهدف سجن غويران في الحسكه الاخضر في
سوريا المنفذون مقاتلون من التنظيم اما
الغايه فتهريب رفاقهم
خطه نفذت مطلع العام الماضي بداها من
الداخل ابرز قاده داعش في السجن نور الدين
بيرم المكلبي ابو محمد الاردني
غسل هذه وهدم هذه الاسواق وكسر هذه القيود
من ايدينا باذن الله عز وجل
[موسيقى]
كان دوري قبل قبل العمل تحرير تحريض على
على الخروج من السجن وعلى خروج الى المخيم
اخراج اخواتنا من سجن مخيم الهول
وهذا قبل العمل طبعا
فشلت خطه الهروب لكن محاوله داعش لا تتوقف
فله في السجون عناصر يعتبرهم الصفوه خبراء
تصنيع متفجرات ومقاتلون مدربون يتكئ عليهم
للعوده من جديد عوده يعتقد الكثير من
عناصر التنظيم في السجن انها حتميه
داعش ليس تنظيما بسيطا او سهلا انه تنظيم
غني ومنظم وشرس للغايه يخطط على المدى
البعيد اعتقد ان هناك فرصه كبيره جدا بان
يعود وان فعل سيكون اكبر واعنف واقوى
[موسيقى]
صحيح ان التنظيم عجز حتى الان عن تهريب
عناصرهم السجون شمال سوريا لكنهما يزال
يحظى بولاء كثيرين منهم كان يعني لا يزال
يعني عندنا ثقه في قيادات ناس خارج
خارج السجن ام داخل السجن وكانت بعض
الوعود تاتي نصدق هذه الوعود يعني لو
اتيحت لك الفرصه مره اخرى للهروب او تخطيط
وتحريط على الهروب تفعلها مليون بالمئه
قطع اي وقت الان وانا جالس معك الان تاتي
فرصه للهرب اهرب اذا خرجت من هذا السجن
ارجع الى القتال في سبيل الله عز وجل اشوف
اهلي طبعا اكيد ضمنا يعني ما احد يعني هذه
امنيه كبيره جدا
الهروب من السجن في مخطط داعش مرحله اولى
تتبعها مرحله لم الشمل وهي اخراج زوجاتي
وابنائي مقاتلي داعش من مخيمي الهول وروش
اما الخطوه الاخيره فهي الاخطر وجهه جديده
يحيي فيها التنظيم دولته المزعومه
يعني اذا تم
انجاز هذا الامر نتفاوض بما يعني حصلنا
عليه من انجازات على الخروج من المنطقه
الى صحراء الانبار او الى صحراء الشاميه
والتفاوض على اخواتنا الاسيرات في مخيم
الهول ومخيم خاصه مخيم من الروج الاسود
اخواتنا المهاجرات يعني للحيلوله دون يعني
دون
تسفيرهن الى الى بلدانهم
الوجهه الصحراء الباديه بسوريا والانبار
في العراق مناطق ينشط فيها التنظيم
ويعتبرها مناسبه لاعاده ترتيب الصفوفه
لكنه يبقى بحاجه الى مقاتله المعتقلين في
سدون سوريا وعددهم 12 الف عنصر كما يحتاج
متعاطفين وانصارا وهؤلاء تعج بهم مخيمات
عائله داعش